the next games
with 2036
yes
Catalan or reti let's see
reti I somehow always have
difficulties against
well I play ambitiously
pretends I know
where there are a lot less tempos here
well well I now have to
try to get through E5  So
I'll try f645
with you so again move
so yes you can't do much
you have to take it out
yes that's my interesting idea in
such a position I'm just wondering if it
even works for him here because I
also have this move
where does the rook go  Now
the quality is off,
I could still play A6 too, well, it
's a source for now,
but he has a very
strong bishop here, so that's
not quite simple yet
and these pawns are also
dangerous
so
I'll try that  and then queen E7
or Q6
to inhibit the farmer here
on four games or something like that, good but or something like that, of
course it works
really pleasantly, it's somehow
still not
I know a lot of game
yes and bishop 5 was of course one
Lemon played really badly,
yes let's go straight back ourselves,
I mean now play a little bit here
C5 well
then I have to take it back
that really a good
a good question
would like to get out of chess if I
draw five here
so well I have to, I think  on
this brilliant field
so now E5
and then hopefully bishop you six
so if he jumps now C4 plays
red knight B6 no
yes but what should I do no
I have to give the quality
back to
yes play quite well no and you
stand here like  like a sausage
man oh man
I made life difficult for myself but I have
no idea yes that's probably just
lost the position
the pawns should pass through
so well B6 threatens and Tom A7 threatens
Thomas
playing D7 helps
a lot
but I doubt it
Yes, I didn't even see that one.
God, what a catastrophe,
but
in the end, somehow he got
some kind of good compensation for it. Yes,
and it's really quite simple now. Yes, there's
not much you can do,
the farmers actually just run
through
God, well, whatever